hey how's it going bros my name is
beatta fat and today i am here with a
very special guest banana i made this
joke so many times welcome to the show
cutie pie my tea
what a beauty what a what a gets our
let's go so hot in your office man deal
with Oh God don't play I lost my
controller don't don't
I'm left this is the sexiest game of all
time Oh two men just mix well I guess
I'm gonna go as well
Bernie kill himself hey I don't want to
smell your rump hey let go of my hair
that's the only piece of hair I had No
aah god damn it Bernie you're just
jealous I got more hair than you
hey oh my god no oh I love you whoa what
what how did you do that
oh god no yeah please please mighty save
me don't let her get my youtube money
nah he is crying it looks sad doesn't it
hey Matt yeah why don't you come over
into this truck what's up what's good
come here girl what's up oh good job
bruh hahaha
how do you do that Oh what are you doing
your characters to a mountain don't oh
my god you're crazy
what are you yeah grab my foot trust me
it's gonna go great no no no how did you
get me what the hell is that that's
[ __ ] in your face every time you go
okay you always lose no I'm doing you
crazy you could hey I got expensive it
could hey give me that epic troll not
yet ha-har dr. Anna into the flames
cast her into the flame yeah yeah how is
it possible huh yes you are the chosen
one
you were supposed to bring balance to
the force
yeah every time ah
I'm knocked unconscious I say I need
your help what are you - nope yeah yeah
I got your tape ha ha ha no more you
gotta Oh Oh
I shared my head I'm buddy this she's
crazy she's a freaking psychopath no no
no no she's gonna sure I got some
buddies - come on
all right now fast
please please oh no what happened
freakin ass
let let me go my ten no no thank you I
thank God huh but now yeah hey hey what
the hell no oh what are you doing
no don't fall that double that I'm
serious don't fund imagine every night's
complete steps
Josh there's a skyscraper right
underneath us I'm going for it that was
higher than I thought
yeah I like that booty oh that booty
make me I mean we booty drop oh god the
signs are coming yeah yeah I got it on
my side duck booty yeah your hair's
going crazy yeah Oh booty now yeah now
huh oh oh no why
we know you did your best and he wasn't
good enough
so yeah I can't talk you do that I like
and favorite if you enjoyed is
favoriting is still thing now just like
this video subscribe for more and food's
gonna cry in corner broke me how these
do the bro fees I'm getting phone try
first right all right
first try
why did I die